Peralta
what do you have to say for yourself the
whole NYPD knows where you are and
they're coming for you right now okay
thanks for the tip let's kill them both
get out of here before the cops come
wait no no no I was lying about the
backup I came alone titled by sex tape
doesn't matter
you're both gonna die now
better get some critical steroids to
treat that laryngeal fracture sorry I
couldn't bring myself to call him a
dirtbag and why would you my Dirtbag is
a very useful part of the vacuum cleaner
clearly it's a compliment
guys are so perfect for
it he's hanging out at the Manhattan
Club right now we can go there and try
and talk to him Jake you can't just walk
into the Manhattan Club it's very
exclusive like how exclusive are we
talking here jeans no jeans more no poor
people of any kind no matter how well
they hide it and more just a tiny slice
of the super rich is it all Illuminati
is it just a whole room full of lizards
Bingo well then I guess we'll have to
transform ourselves
into the uber wealthy
[Applause]
Charles turn that music off oh sorry I
was just practicing in case you guys
changed your mind what we have is a
classic whodunit the phrase whodunit is
a grammatical Abomination please use the
proper term a who has done this I will
not however in order to solve this case
we need the very finest of detectives
one with a unique set of skills someone
named gentleman I'll call Dillman
who
thank you
[Music]
you need some help with the who has done
this
Halloween
it's ice time
I thought you hit a head start on Heist
prep good luck I'm already dressed well
I'm also dressed and I made breakfast
wait where are my eggs in my belly
yeah
Falcon one do we have a go
the light is green tiger one what are
you gonna say when he crashed through
the window hey there sorry for dropping
in Goosebumps Jake Goosebumps it's
equipment secure check weapon loaded
check did you have breakfast what that's
not on the checklist I added it because
I care about you no I did not have
breakfast unacceptable look in your
pocket
hey there's a little chocolate chips in
this yeah I'm not an idiot I know how to
trick my best friend into eating as
fiber all right bar digested mission go
hey there
sorry for dropping in
was it cool it felt really cool yeah
yeah it's pretty cool pretty cool but
we're wrong I think
oh from the breakfast bar boil you know
killing a man is not as easy as it
sounds
I've killed 10 men and that's such a
nice round number wouldn't you agree I
mean imagine I've killed 11 people it
just sounds so
cumbersome
kayak got the buckets boil you did it
and you completely botched the
catchphrase I'm pretty sure it was right
no but you did great are you okay sorry
I shot you I thought that's what the nod
meant it was it was awesome it was
actually just like the end of speed
which is a pretty good movie it's not as
good as I heard tires for Vegas yeah I
was gonna say she keep going after
figures same page still
out of the car
[Music]
[Applause]
lost and found at the storage facility
they have boxes on them they're
everywhere I didn't call it I thought
you did what I did no such thing so if
neither of you called it then who did
awesome
be here wow I can't believe I executed
that to Perfection that was amazing Tina
what's this all about I wanted to make
one final grand entrance final what do
you mean I've decided to leave the nine
nine which is why
okay
[Music]
I'm handing in my two weeks notice
me I have no idea that it's me
just hope I'm ready
wow come on guys I know you're sad but
let's do our best to make a good first
impression here smart good call Jake you
be up front
[Music]
here we go
hello I'm your new command and officer
Captain Seth dozerman my motto is simple
efficiency efficiency efficiency can
probably just say it once are you making
fun of my stutter oh uh tricked you I
don't have a stutter boom I've already
established my authority through my
amazing sense of humor well done sir
welcome to the nine nine I'm Sergeant
Terry Jeffers and I'm not interested I
have no use for people I find people
weird and confusing I Live My Life by
Numbers you see this watch it tells me
how many calories I burn at any time
question how many calories you think I
burned walking from there to there you
female closest to me oh uh
three three
try 0.8 numb nuts I made promises to my
superiors that I most certainly cannot
keep that's why I need you idiots to
work twice as hard no no strike that
four times as hard no no strike that I
need I knew morons to work eight times
harder than
I'm having a heart attack
yeah I'm having a heart attack get back
to work
the doctor
Jake hurry up I'm starving sorry sorry
sorry sorry
to grab my wall
gentlemen
fine I was trying something and it
didn't work I've assembled a team of
powerful allies in the NYPD no that's
too risky how do you know they're not
loyal to John Kelly because these people
aren't loyal to anybody
[Music]
I made a Suicide Squad Hey Jake can I
show you something over here sure thing
but I'm trying to send Genevieve a sexy
pic just move my bubble butt pop nope
I'm out
that I don't know
um excuse me
don't be a dumb dumb squad meet
detective Adrian pimento he's been deep
undercover for the last 12 years but
he's just resurfaced and he's rejoining
the nine nine that yeah
awesome
so what happened I guess I wasn't ready
to say goodbye to my family
good
neither will we I know what I'm picking
up on is just a genuine moment of
friendship and respect
and now I'm feeling like you wish I
would stop analyzing you because I'm
ruining a moment
but you guys are so cute I love you all
rise for the honorable Judge marinovich
please
where's Mr Peralta objection
like
myself
[Music]
Mr Peralta what is the meaning of this